oi oi oi oi oi oi
donc j'ai créé un point pour voir son
entrée
merci beaucoup d'être là c'est une belle
expérience qu'on peut vivre ce soir
j'aimerais si je pense après monkey
avoir plus radiophonique ever ça fait un
peu ch notre pauvre mais pour le faire
rapporter un peu j'aimerais qu'on donne
une grosse main d'applaudissement a tout
les organisateurs la soirée comment
common rail
k
car m'a approché pour faire cet
événement là on me dit que le thème
général c'était le changement donc moi
tout de suite j'avais le titre en tête
de mon numéro qui était de devenir grand
et non je parle pas de mes cheveux je
parle du fait que moi et ma blonde
on a pris la décision d'avoir un enfant
donc c'est sûr que quand comprends cette
décision le lieu tout d'un coup un
million d'experts qui viennent te voir
qui donne l'heure juste sur ce que c'est
avoir un enfant et il ya aussi la
technologie maintenant
et puis ma blonde pour s'amuser dans
l'eau d'une application qui lui disait
séquences épiques d'ovulation
au début je pensais que c'était une joke
jusqu'à tac j'arrive chez nous soient
calmes à regarder que ses yeux kendy
henri-gout mes culottes sont on va pas
assez vite soit pas embarrassant dire ça
parce que mes beaux-parents son lanceur
donc après ça le tableau d un autre
application qui lui disait si on faisait
du lundi au jeudi salle est un garçon si
on faisait du vendredi au dimanche
sahara est une fille c'est pas un voyage
à cuba que je veux c'est un enfant merci
malgré que je prendrai deux ces temps ci
m'ont dit moins 40 en marbre même si
l'idée d'avoir un enfant tout chaud avec
les technologies c'est cool mais il ya
toujours des trucs de grand mère qu'on
se fait dire comme par exemple ma blonde
n'est sûrement besoin d'un support des
bobettes série ça a plus de chances
d'être 1 go si on fait l'amour et qui
musique romantique des petites
chandelles a plus de chances d'être une
fille si je mange des serial le matin ça
reste plus des tangos si après avoir
fait l'amour je me laisse légende désert
dont tout juste la force ça sera fini
par tout
donc c'est une superbe aventure dans
laquelle on se lance
mais sérieusement ça ne fait pas ça me
fait peur parce que même si j'ai 27 ans
dans ma tête je suis pas un adulte c'est
encore un orage encore douze ans dans ma
tête mais j'entends déjà les faits dire
oui mais vous oubliez que vous n'êtes
pas mathieu banane on met les choses au
clair
nous autres les go on sait comment se
faire du fun que vous êtes jaloux de se
sevrer les gars ah ouais
les gosses ont permis à tout un work
baisse apparaît à l ego donc j'ai
réalisé que j'étais pas encore un adulte
après une grosse journée de travail je
t'ai j'allais à l'école je travaille et
je pense j'ai passé 20 heures de chez
nous je reviens juste parfaite skippy ma
blonde à mieux acheter une boîte de
blocs lego hamas une boîte de blocs lego
parce qu'elle savait que j'avais une
grosse journée
savez vous ce que j'ai fait quand j'ai
reçu la boîte
ben je lui ai ouvert puis j'ai fait les
lego puis j'étais en indien puis jetée
legault le plus heureux au monde
c'est là que je me sens du compte
quelque chose qui clochait je me suis
rendu compte que je t'ai pas encore
totalement un adulte parce que en
amérique du nord soit peu ambiguë si on
regarde il ya des tribus des races
humaines que devenir un adulte qui
t'envoient à 9,1 d'argent tu es le plus
gros souci que père a porté sa peau où
il y en a d'autres tribus qu'il faut que
tu restes sur un billot pendant trois
jours sans dormir moujoud légaux je fais
des lego jeu des familles lego se
construit des châteaux pour mais les
gones joe g sérieux donc si je
réfléchissais à tout ce que j prix des
doutes légaux comme modèle leur père
donc j'ai analysé un peu mon papy mon
père lui faire plaisir d'un spa
déléguons du 1er mai a dit trop gros
doigts il peut tuer n'importe qui et que
ses doigts lui qui donne aux gens le
tournevis en mode le scout ouest utah
rosen et que tu peux partir ton char
couper des arbres du palais au garage
remontera peachum comme trophée de
guerre
bonjour les goûts des fois quand of duty
départ du monde
donc je me suis mis à réfléchir qu'est
ce qui freine mois un adulte je me suis
au québec c'est simple de 18 ans devient
adulte mais je pense pas que ce soit
aussi simple que sur parce que quand je
regarde les ondes a renié par exemple un
autre c'est une méchante gang de faux
qu'il a 19 ans vient l'adulte mais pour
le reste de ta vie tu t'habilles comme
un trip d'acide
il s'habille vraiment aller donc je
regardais aussi au niveau des états unis
aux etats unis c'est 21 à grenade où tu
considère un adulte pendant le coach
eric gerets bla bla bla sauf que tu peux
rentrer dans l'armee à 18 heures donc
c'est un peu comme dire qu'ils envoient
des enfants dans des pays en guerre pour
faire cesser ces mêmes pays en guerre
d'envoyer des enfants à la guerre c'est
un peu fort qui s'amassent aux jo
politique nous bouffe de pouvoir était
de saigner du nez une fable donc je me
suis dit ah ça doit être un peu comme
comme les tribus dans la jambe je revois
un rite de passage que j'ai fait je m'en
suis peut-être pas aperçu donc j'ai
réfléchi je me suis peut-être que je
suis devenu un adulte quand j'étais au
sujet moi j'étais au cégep de rois ainsi
j'ai fait mon dec en travail social
c'est toujours mieux qu un dec en
sciences humaines on s'entend qu'il faut
à venir
donc le jeu réfléchir un peu hippie
c'est probablement la période de ma vie
où j'ai fumé le plus de potes ça fait
pas très adulte de trouver que la
couleur violette un drôle de nom pendant
deux semaines
donc après je continue à réfléchir je
vais continuer sur cette piste là je me
suis dit d'avoir quelque chose de plus
je me suis dit c'est peut-être la
première fois que j'ai décidé de devenir
humoriste de faire la scène pour la
première fois parce que ça prenne moyens
dose de courage pour venir sur scène
la première fois vizir des job parce que
le monde irie pour t'encourager il
trouve pathé docks drôle mais finalement
je me suis hors c'est juste pour avoir
librement la renier juan public face à
avai par rapport au fait que je
continuais j j'ai remué comme ça un peu
tout ce que j'avais pu faire
puis finalement je suis tombé sur
quelque chose c'était une conversation
que j'avais vu avec mon père qui
m'expliquait un peu trop en détail
ma conception je vous mets je m'appelle
un contexte ma mère et mon père n'ont
jamais vraiment vraiment être ensemble
sont rencontrés d'importer et puis
lyon est dispo en big bang neuf mois
après chun et donc ça vaut même pas mal
un contexte je voulais pas trop savoir
ce qui s'était passé
donc mon père commence à josy de
t'choupi en fait on était ma blonde
m'avait donné des billets pour
l'ouverture la cage aux sports à rouyn
noranda et le tout était gratuit qu'on
s'entend pour dire qu'en abitibi notre
sport national
c'est beau n'est ce pas qu'on ait
vendredi le sympathique vous ensemble et
un pad et montréal et à vendre un peu
déçu donc depuis mon père on enfile les
bières comme ça on était une série de
six victoires à domicile bref ça va donc
à peu près deux ans après qu'on soit
arrivé puis une dizaine de bières chaque
mon père il embarque sujet mais comme
vraiment cycle le sujet pour ma mère
donc on est on est assis au bar publiées
comme en ce que mon gars si jamais
secousses d'un lead où ça va te donner
dix journées mon appartement pour cette
voie là opposants je préfère l'avoir
fait comme en face de beaux lots moi je
croyais on pas jamais dormi d'un leader
je sais pas de quoi tu parles
c'est parce que quelques moues de
toronto fait on vonier inquiries steve o
pas comment dire soldats - ta mère est
une petite coquine america prenait la
pilule mais ça a l'air d'un bon sac à
main comment en plus effilé
l'on avait dit on au parti mais elle
n'avait à tabarre ou étant pas fois que
je m'en moque c'est vrai que finalement
je m'en vais aux toilettes
pour les 30 minutes après je jure la
serveuse est venu porter deux bières aux
toilettes parce que je devais pour
oublier
je sais pas à les revoir mon père je
voulais pas plus de détails
pis si la queue avec tout ça je me suis
rendu compte que je vais peut-être
toujours être un enfant malgré tout
changement qui arrive dans ma vie je
veux toujours vouloir goûter la porte à
moi dieu ou chocolat jo toujours vouloir
même collé la langue c'est un poteau
pour savoir si qu'elle le plus tough
change à cette fois vous aurez posé que
les scores vous allez être déçus j'ai
toujours un petit frisson quand je passe
en avant des jouets want me dire t'es
pas game ça marche encore
mais je veux toujours resté un enfant
aux yeux de certains adultes aux yeux
d'autres pays récemment j'ai eu la plus
belle nouvelle au monde
ma blonde m'a annoncé qu'étant enceinte
puis c'est une super de belle aventure
parce que même si on voulait le faire
c'est venu un peu comme une surprise
parce que c'était pas encore temps prévu
je suis vraiment content parce qu'enfin
jeu pour avoir retenu pour jouer aux
lego
merci beaucoup demain merci